cuatro días antes de que fueran a
caducar las medidas de apoyo social que
España había aprobado para hacer frente
a los efectos de la guerra en Ucrania el
presidente del gobierno español Pedro
Sánchez ha renovado algunas de las
medidas ya implementadas como por
ejemplo la gratuidad de ciertos trenes o
el transporte público pero ha anunciado
varias medidas nuevas entre las más
destacadas de este nuevo paquete anti
crisis está la eliminación al 0% del IVA
en los alimentos de primera necesidad
como el pan los huevos el queso la leche
la fruta o la verdura por otro lado el
aceite o la pasta que en el último año
se habían encarecido entre un 20 y un
31% tendrán su IVA reducido a la mitad
es decir al 5% esto durante al menos
seis meses además las familias que
ingresen menos de 27.000 euros al año
recibirán un cheque por 200 euros una
ayuda para lidiar con la inflación que
llegaría a más de 4 millones de hogares
en España sin embargo una de las medidas
que fue Igualmente criticada como
popular termina es la subvención de los
20 céntimos por litro en gasolina y
diésel que se aplicaba a todo el mundo y
que a partir del año que viene será sólo
para transportistas profesionales
agricultores navieras o Pescadores este
paquete de más de 10.000 millones de
euros entrará en vigor el 1 de enero de
2023 un año recordemos marcado por
elecciones generales un monto que será
un tercio de lo que recaudó en 2022 el
Estado a través de impuestos una
cantidad que superó en un 17% a lo
recibido por el estado el año anterior